perché tu sei abbracciando cucina mi
sento più protetti da tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti questo video sono pari j
e oggi sono con i miei amici che sono
gabriele nichi scherza prima di
cominciare vi faccio vedere l'ora
d'orario l'una di notte quasi sta per
scattare luna scatta che così faccio le
big views perfetto adesso è l'una di
notte perché sarà 0 59 non faceva
abbastanza paura e niente ragazzi allora
è uscita la demo di residenti vol 7 sul
playstation network e ho detto vabbè
giochiamolo insieme all'oro maniera
europea esa e dire di partire questa
demo visto che se no non partiamo bello
per questo paese lo kitty nella testa la
poltrona che volevo mettere là dietro ho
visto l'altro giorno con un cane bene
tuttavia non andiamo starò è bello
giocare a sta roba l'una di notte perché
i miei vicini sicuramente saranno
contentissimi infatti salutiamo vicini
ciao vicini ciao
so che state scopando l'aviaria c'è un
intro qualcosa o parte subito a bello
direi che parte subito anche mi sta
facendo il video è perché lo in basso a
sinistra e il tifoso italiano dopo aver
visto la partita s'è ripreso però la
mamma sono in tv
certo che calzi videochiamate saleh che
con chip arm ma che cazzo fa va bene c'è
un coltello sembra un calcio scarpe
ovviamente o prenderà la nutella col
contenuti libera ci libera cipro state
lo usa come se fosse della chicco
mi piace ai delle skill zio cos'è questo
gioco ancora in fase di sviluppo e me lo
dici adesso dopo che tipo ho provato a
tagliare la corda a perché quando lo
sviluppa non riesce ad esso non riuscirò
coltello ed e affilato e riusciva perché
il gioco in fase invece di dire mi sto
già muovendo presidenti vo il set che
della mano sexy ma sono quello di prima
bella la poltrona trova una via d'uscita
per me non la volevo rimanere qua dentro
perché mi piace l'ambientazione salve
oddio emi e mio prof se stai guardando
questo video ne stavano scherzando ma va
ragazzi l'arredamento è buono la tv
prender hd
mica vhs mi chiamo i cartoni animati
collega se ti serve una videocassetta
scusa cenerentola la chiusura non volevo
passavano tagliando la fiorentina la
bistecca
dobbiamo cercare la videocassetta è un
possibile perché la carezza le porte
nello stesso giorno è bello se porta
quasi apre bello per lui accarezza le
porte cioè noi che ma la maniglia in
vico york a cosa sta facendo il suo
cuore al suo gioco c'è anche un
inventario mani grafica cia rega
che belli fuori di te li prepara
qualcosa nave dire di no perchè ci vivo
da roma nel piatto tra sicuramente
qualcosa di più genuino di quello che
cucino io attenzione buono ragazzi e la
grandezza e poi su una carezza ma anche
lo scalea è un po crudo perché tipo il
sushi sì ma anzi usa mangiare ma tale ha
detto loro di ripulire nel lavandino
prima di questo caso mettete non è
caduta schiacciando poteva l'apparenza
forte giorno c'è una mucca tagliata a
metà prezzo in quanto società che non
entri mai in casa tua vedi una mucca per
terra tagliata loro terre amadei maglie
non si chiede come più lontana da dove
non c'era niente ma cos'è perché sono
bello gli sporchi dato c'è la luce e poi
giorno fuori ti serve una chiave per
uscire ma porca [ __ ] una porta di legno
a si può aprire quel tenaglie legalità
una video filmato casa abbandonata o
andare sul blog asd prima irata poi lo
metti del re leone provato io di lo
guarderei volentieri re leone ma
cerchiamo di sopra bello bello
citiamo di so no ma scusate il pianista
proprio non semplice o fantasma di cui
mi posso palpare scommetti che non lo
palpa questo non lo sa che lei è visto
era se le borse chiuse perché esatto che
accarezza le polveri ma non c'è non
c'era prima quest'anno
vabbè vabbè ragazze una alla volta lo so
che sono un figo però ma queste non
siamo le braccia ha ceduto sante rosso
scale scale ma compaiono tre scusa mi
piace a me mi dispiace non volevo farlo
giorno quale le gioie che dura nel
dubbio ti butto pure giu
sì però stai calmo papa ragazzi
vediamoci storie leone che ce lo
togliamo in fretta
vorrei bello il quadro lunga mi chiama
grafica così non ora per i ragazzi l'ho
vista pochissimo ma giocare sempre
adesso c'è tipo la bambina di the ring
che va bene mette più brutto questo a
casa è questa qui sono un po di legna
telli cosa che adesso la possibilità di
confrontarmi col ponte conto alcuno cioè
poi mi spiegate perchè negli horror la
gente deve andare dice il case
abbandonate che porca [ __ ] guarda
guarda perché dovresti imparare una casa
che c'è questa cosa di quei due detto
questo continua a fare le porte per non
si aprono trovare lavoro e aprono esiste
roma detersivo ciclo con vista spingere
il dio tu siete solo incastrato
quell'applauso dai tagli e degli extra
cosa non era ci voglio venire dentro mi
costringono riguarda rip alfano ho
risolto molto gravi beh vi poteva fare
così anche con la porta di prima perché
non lo ha fatto prima
cazzo vuoi tu guardi è la stessa fatta
la prima è quella rossa quella per
avermi chiama avuto un calo così per
uscire
quindi lui può entrare così e non posso
uscire va bene la prendo rinforzate c'è
stato un omicidio dentro sta a casa non
capì possiamo chiudere la porta per
cercare scherzavo maestro registrando
non l'avevo capita sta cosa domandato
quello dove andato e non lo so non ho
visto colori è andato da qualche parte
di sparito ci sono anche manichini
scommetti non ci sei manichini gli
ammessi dopo dov'è andato il tizio
nostro delle cuffie delle cuffie beati
ragazzi tanto sembrano le mitiche
bellissime sentito dai calci alle porte
che sono impedito non posso vado a fuoco
una lentezza incredibile compilando
romano esatto che non la prego di sì
ma non era quello che mi tagliava la
corda all'inizio del secolo emerge
proprio essere ammoniti sta raccontando
perché se in quella casa e può essere si
è ficcato dentro come babbo natale al
contrario
riguardo la porta più che quella ho
paura che qualcuno entri la porta mi
chiedi mi va bene aperto il passaggio
segreto ok è un ippogrifo che shop a
stanare ci sarà uno show è visto l'ombra
se c'è un'ombra vero molto bene mi
guardo continuamente dietro perché mica
go addosso poi qualcuno arrivi dietro
bello in un mulo in paglia di
esattamente quello che volevo vedere
dall'inizio del gioco su permesso quindi
adesso so che la dietro c'è un c'è un
passaggio questo posso farvi una domanda
se questo questa registrando come mai le
mani sono tutte queste scalagroup ero in
testa sono al massimo perché non è
possibile
andrei
ecco secondo me sta bello aveva
associare la sete poterlo
faccia agli occhi heine collirio e
calcolando invito a non era il mio amico
direi di no fa bello tra cagando o video
che ha fatto ripartire con questo è
stato lo lascio un messaggio ti sistra
sceglierò contro la pietra
buon natale anche attenti quindi io
adesso devo dare per scontato che qua
dietro ci siamo un passaggio segreto
giusto e dorato ha preso il titano solo
a guardarlo nel mondo porc aveva
permesso
ma adesso vado sotto c'è ancora il
cadavere o colla dove sono chiudere
quella che non scenderei tra l'altro
post inter è pronto non faccio così
chiave porta posteriore perfetto grazie
stato bello e fatemi solo guardare per
sfizio annunciato pescara 9 gli wire
sono contento così contentissimo
non volevo una crescente porta
posteriore quale la porta posteriore
guarda quella roba mica possiamo uscire
a
ripensandoci la scala non era così male
ma quella era la barba e del vino e del
miseria o in uno ciascuno dei due abbia
messo male
si va dai ragazzi però
è però vero che poi fatto cagare che la
porta posteriore questa qui siano sicuri
vaffan con lo forte che sa fare ed è ben
altra come ci è arrivato questo maggiori
casa ci fanno questi pare che c'è il
pallone il culo nostra delibera ragazzi
ci arriveremo sicuramente senza morire
sono fiducioso certo è vero ma casa a
prova portando la cassiera o dai fan
culo per l'ultimo td a prendere tutta la
città faceva lì si era lui argento e mi
ha legato è ben chiaro quella da dove è
uscita ha detto ma chi è
[Applauso]
io non ti ho fatto niente bella
simpatica un paio di trucchi da chicco
li trovi nè la famiglia ti attende ora
che amo la notte penso che cazzo di
conca ragazzi questo era il finale è
sicuramente più bello d italia germania
system è molto più bella rete il
gameplay completo quando esce il gioco
50.000 leitner questo non lo faccio io
ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto è
concluso bene episodio classe anche se
vi è piaciuta stato commento mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook e commentate
in cities che ci mettiamo prossimo
va bene la ragazza